der nächste redner ist mal den hess aus
der fdp-fraktion präsident verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen innenminister
wenn man ihre aussagen zur inneren
sicherheitslage hört dann kann ein
objektiver außen gebracht und nur zu
einem schluss kommen also entweder
leiden sie unter einer massiven störung
der realitätswahrnehmung oder sie reden
sich die lage schlicht schön das
passierte in bezug auf die
sicherheitslage dargestellt haben hat
mit der lebenswirklichkeit in unserem
land nichts zu tun deutschland wird
immer unsicherer um unser rechtsstaat
verliert immer mehr roten an seine
feinde
das ist die unumstößliche wahrheit und
jeder normal denkende mensch in diesem
land erkennt dass auch wenn warum sonst
müssen sind immer mehr geld für die
innere sicherheit ausgeben warum sonst
müssen sie für einen stellen aufwuchs
bei sicherheitsbehörden sollten wir in
deutschland doch angeblich so sicher ist
wie seit 30 jahren nicht mehr
herr minister der bürger lässt sich
nicht für dumm verkaufen und erkennt
diese widersprüche sie erzählen den
bürgern unseres landes nur aus einem
einzigen grund ständig das wiederholte
märchen vom ach so sicheren deutschland
sie wollen über ihr angelegt ismus
kämpfendes sicherheitspolitisches
versagen hinwegtäuschen
aber ich sage ihnen immer mehr bürger
durchschauen diese farce und da hilft es
auch nichts dass sie ständig versuchen
den bürgern einzureden ihr subjektives
sicherheitsempfinden hören nicht der
tatsächlichen lage entsprechend ganz so
als würden sich unsere bürger nur
einbilden dass deutschland immer
unsicherer wird es wird doch gerade in
diesen tagen auf den weihnachtsmärkten
im ganzen land für jeden offensichtlich
wir hier tatsächlich unter einer
massiven wahrnehmungsstörung leidet
unsere kinder werden sich an keine
weihnachten mehr ohne terror sperren und
schwer bewaffnete polizisten erinnern
können und genau das ist der zentrale
beleg ihres versagens und bestätigt dass
die bürger recht haben sie versuchen mit
diesem haushalt sicherheitspolitische
probleme zu beseitigen die es ohne ihr
inakzeptables versagen im bereich der
inneren sicherheit gar nicht gäbe hätte
die bundesregierung die richtigen
entscheidungen getroffen dann wäre
deutschland heute wesentlich sicherer
sie hatten
und haben die möglichkeit eine
sicherheitspolitik umzusetzen die zu
einem maximalen schutz unserer bürger
führt aber genau hier bei einer
zentralen um nicht zu sagen bei der 10
13 aufgabe unseres staates versagen sie
täglich mit fatalen folgen für leben
gesundheit freiheit und eigentum unserer
brüder dieses sicherheitspolitische
desaster können und werden wir weder
akzeptieren noch hinnehmen die
größtmögliche sicherheit unserer bürger
muss endlich hergestellt werden und
dabei darf es keine kompromisse geben
sie programmieren hier immer die
verteidigung unserer grund und
werteordnung tun aber genau das
gegenteil sie wollen allen ernstes an
moscheen 7 millionen euro steuergelder
verteilen um die integration zu fördern
und das auch an die tig moscheen obwohl
die sicherheitsbehörden sagen dass die
tib massive staatsfeindliche aktivitäten
entfaltet und deshalb eigentlich
nachrichtendienst überwacht werden
müsste sie finanzieren islamisten und
salafisten dass herr minister mit man
die bock zum gärtner machen bei
finanzierung von staatsfeinden machen
wir nicht mit
wer mit offenen augen durch unsere
republik geht erkennt jeden tag wie
schlimm es um unsere sicherheitslage
bestellt ist die islamistische
terrorgefahr so hoch wie nie die
migranten und messer kriminalität steigt
stetig an schwere sexualdelikte wie
gruppen vergewaltigungen neben zu frauen
und kinder werden mittlerweile für
einfahrende züge gestoßen
krankenhäuser frei bei jedoch schulen
und shops ein paar kommen ohne
sicherheitsdienste nicht mehr aus die
angriffe gegen polizei feuerwehr
rettungskräfte werden immer brutaler und
kleinkriminelle tyrannisieren ganze
stadtteile stürmen polizeiwachen und
krankenhäuser und die
sicherheitsbehörden konstatieren einen
massiven zulauf und warnen vor neuen
gefährlichen clans mit kriegs erfahrenen
zuwanderern
das sind kriegsmaschinen diese mit ihrer
vorteile migrationspolitik ungehindert
in unser land lassen und das ist ein
skandal und in der hauptstadt dürfen
drogendealer mit billigung und bildung
aller staatlichen institutionen völlig
ungehindert drogen verkaufen war wohl
nichts mit dem sichersten deutschland
aller zeiten im gegenteil deutschland
ist offensichtlich zu einem
sicherheitspolitischen
irrenhaus mutiert angesichts dieser
verheerende bilanz bleibt mir nur ein
eindringlicher appell
es ist ihre aufgabe die bürger
bestmöglich zu schützen
fangen sie um gottes willen endlich
damit an martin hess aus der fdp
fraktion zeichnet ein gänzlich anderes
bild von der inneren sicherheit als der
bundesinnenminister und